so Rubio out of nowhere tweets out any
political reporter commentator claiming
Christy ended my campaign in 2016 is
lazy or dumb New Hampshire debates
sucked because instead of hitting back
when attacked like I wanted to I
listened to advice about pivoting and
not punching down on Chris Christie who
is at seven percent about to drop out
but it didn't end my campaign after New
Hampshire I finished second in South
Carolina in Nevada won three primaries
almost one Virginia on super Tuesday
finished with the third most delegates
behind the Trump's historic campaign and
was elected re-elected twice by 8 and 17
points
ah
I like Marco Rubio this is a weak sauce
man his defense is one I didn't follow
my instincts and I listened to whatever
the Consultants told me so don't blame
me it's the consultant's fault it
doesn't make you look good and then two
it's not convincing anybody